[Music]
now how did
gambling or interest
in
those types of applications of physics
or mathematics enter the picture for you
well i'm a curious person and you could
say that it happened purely by chance
when i was teaching ucla
i got interested in
beating blackjack somebody
told me about an article that
would let me let me play almost even
so
one christmas vacation my wife and i
went out it was actually
christmas vacation of 1958 when i
just after i got my phd we went out to
las vegas and i never gambled because i
knew it was
a loser for most people
and uh the odds were against you but i i
bet 10
and i played for about 40 minutes and i
had an interesting experience the first
20 minutes i had a little card telling
me what to do and people thought i was a
fool
who
knew nothing about the game and
they were right that i knew nothing
about the game but the card made me much
smarter than the other players
and so
i made some remarkable plays that
attracted their attention and then they
all hovered around they wanted to see
how i was making these plays and one of
them i got a
seven card
21
which
is very rare
and in most places paid a bonus they
didn't pay moments in this particular
place but they thought i was trying for
that and i somehow managed to produce it
so i realized they didn't know much
about the game really and i went back
and
read carefully the statistics article
and realized that i could see from my
math background
how to actually
devise the system to beat the game so i
then i i set about to do it
and
about that time i
moved from ucla to mit and i had access
to the big computers
at mit this was back in
1959 they had an ibm 704 which was a
refrigerator-sized machine that served
30 new england universities so i taught
myself how to program
and as i worked my way through with my
ideas i saw that
i had a winning system and it was just a
matter of finishing all the calculations
so i went ahead and did that
and
then i
wanted to find out
i wanted to get this
system published because i thought that
from my experience in mathematics and
what i've seen happen elsewhere
other people would claim they did it and
grab the credit
and i
that annoyed me because it already
happened to be mathematics a couple of
times
so i went shopping for somebody who
could get me quick publication
and
turned out that on the mit campus
there was a man who i knew nothing about
named claude shannon
who was
an institute professor and he was a
member of the national academy of
sciences
so he could get me
if he approved of what i wrote a quick
publication in the proceedings of the
national academy it would only take a
couple of months to get it out so i
looked him up
one day and
the secretary at mit's math department
said there's no point in going to see
him he doesn't see people
he's very private and if you do get to
see him you're only going to have five
minutes
so
i i finally managed to see him at lunch
for five minutes
and uh after we talked
he said well looks like you've got all
the main ideas here uh yes i'll put this
through but we have to change the title
the title was
a winning strategy for blackjack
and
he changed it to something like uh
a favorable strategy for 21 which
sounded better
he didn't want to make too bold a
statement for the national academy
and make it look like
this was a just a gambling paper
so anyhow the paper got sent in and it
caused a sensation because i had
submitted an abstract to it to the
american mathematical society meeting in
washington dc where i was going to
present
by the way
they initially rejected the abstract
saying that this is just another fool
with a system that doesn't work because
we know you can't beat gambling games
but
on the abstract committee was a
person i knew well from ucla a number
theorist named john selfridge
became quite well known in number theory
and he said well if thorpe says it's
true it probably is so you should accept
this abstract
so i went there and i presented and i
thought there'd be about 50
mathematicians in the audience but
instead there were
300 people it was jammed
and a lot of people were very odd
looking they had pinky rings on and
sunglasses and
tropical shirts in the middle of winter
so
after i finish they lunge for my little
handout i brought 50 handouts thinking
that's all i would need there and i
basically tossed the handouts out and
left as quickly as i could then it was
picked up by a fellow named
tom wolf who became a famous american
novelist
and he wrote
he was a young reporter then he wrote a
piece for ap which
went across the country and so it got
massive press
and that led to me writing a book
and uh
telling everybody how to do it after a
couple of years
between the time i wrote the book though
and when i told people how to do it by
publishing
i went out and played blackjack myself
and
proved the system worked
i figured that there's no point in
writing a book unless i knew it really
worked i knew it worked in theory
but what if you actually tried to do it
and you know a lot of things they seem
to work in theory but when you get down
and actually put something to the test
you find out there are all kinds of
things you didn't think of
it turned out in this case
it worked very well
we made
in one weekend with a test eleven
thousand dollars which
is about that with a zero on the end uh
in today's money
this isn't about 20 hours of serious
play
so i had
a lunch money at mit for a very long
time thereafter
you